on m'a dit que j'étais vice-président
donc à rien écoutez je n'ai pas le goût
du ridicule je n'ai jamais eu le goût de
ne rien faire
donc bien sûr je quitte le front
national et le président des patriotes
n'est pas le seul à déserter son
vice-président aussi maxime thiébaut ex
responsable régional de debout la france
le parti de nicolas dupont aignan avait
rejoint le front national en mais
aujourd'hui il le quitte lui aussi et ne
cache pas sa surprise devant l'attitude
de marine le pen
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que à ce que
la scission viennent parce que je
pensais de marine le pen allait avoir
une une commande ya un peu de raison
dardé faire battre ses convictions et je
suis déçu aujourd'hui alors je désespère
pas à ce que les choses se rétablissent
dans les années à venir
mais en tout cas je suis très déçu de
l'attitude de marine le pen elle a
choisi des pressions politiques qui vont
l'amener à un parti politique qui va se
se refermer sur lui-même qu'yvan
rassembler plus personne dans les rangs
des patriotes proches de florian
philippot les annonces de départ
logiquement s'enchaînent des mises de la
présidence du groupe fn au conseil
régional
sophie montel s'éloigne en dénonçant une
remobilisation du front national comme
lee en noir aux élus à la région lui
aussi il ne renouvellera pas sa carte le
front national prend une direction dans
laquelle je ne retrouve aucune de mes
convictions aucune de ma valeur moi je
suis gaulliste je suis patriote je suis
souverainiste et je suis républicain et
assister pour s'orienter vers une telle
ligne
convoqué par quelques quelques cadres
monsieur baer aliot ou encore monsieur
collard et monsieur bild non je ne
participerai pas de ce nouveau front au
soir du second tour de la présidentielle
pourtant lilian noirot applaudissaient
un temps révolu pour l'élu de
saône-et-loire et tous les fidèles de
florian philippot